grâce à la participation de plusieurs
observateurs bénévoles entre eux ont pu
suivre la population depuis plusieurs
années on a mis en place un suivi de la
population
et puis un peu partout à travers la
province à la fin mai début juin 50 60
personnes qui nous a aidé à faire des
décomptes de marché dont elle déçoit ont
pris si tout le monde s'en faire des
dépenses qui vous permettront d'avoir
une idée de la taille minimale la
population au québec d'aller passer en
2013 ont le même choix je pense que le
22 mai 2013 du tapis de sol mais qu'ils
ont été compris la famille bénévoles qui
nous aident donc ça nous donne une bonne
idée de la taille minimale la population
de détection de réseaux est ce que l'on
constate que déclin continu ça se
stabilise sous serment
depuis quelques années le déclin est
moins n'ayant pas de route en vue mais
le déclin semble le groupe décrit un
lieu d'où coule dans les fin des années
60 70 80 depuis les années 90 le déclin
et plus jeunes ils sont pointés vers
nenê ici ouais ça fait peut-être
l'épopée ou le les changements dans
l'environnement et elle n'est plus le
plus marqué